it is one of the country's most
expensive diseases and it's also the
seventh
leading cause of death now november is
national diabetes awareness month and
it's a really good time to explore the
physical
and also the financial impacts of the
disease as well as to what to look out
for
in fact every year an estimated 10 000
people
in our state are diagnosed with diabetes
and people with a condition
have medical costs nearly two and a half
times higher than others
the average patient can spend more than
nine thousand dollars a year on health
care costs so what is troubling is that
roughly seventy five thousand nevadans
have diabetes and they don't even know
it
the number one risk factor is obesity if
you're overweight
your chances of being diagnosed
skyrocket other causes include high
blood pressure
high cholesterol and inactivity and if
you smoke
that increases your risk by nearly 40
percent
now those with diabetes will also live
shorter lives too up to 14 years less
for a woman
and 18 years less for a man so on
saturday which is world diabetes day
you are encouraged to adopt a healthy
lifestyle and also know the warning
signs if you're
hungry and fatigued maybe you're going
to the bathroom more often you're
thirstier
dry mouth itchy skin losing weight but
you're not trying to
blurred vision all of those are risk
factors and you should look into it
it's important because every year ten
thousand nevadans are diagnosed with
diabetes